[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Ashley's
with us in Philadelphia hi Ashley
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's
up so my boyfriend is receiving a pretty
large settlement um in the next coming
months and we're kind of debating uh
we're looking to buy our first home um
and obviously once the home comes
uh once the right home comes we'll we'll
do that but he's stuck on paying the
house out in full um and I'm wondering
it's better to do a big down payment and
get a mortgage on the house why do you
want a
mortgage I don't I don't know I feel
like putting a huge lump of that
settlement into a house why do why do
you want to
mortgage I I'm not I'm not sure well you
just told me you wanted a
mortgage
what do you think he should do with
it I I just want him to use it as wisely
as possible um sounds like he wants to
avoid debt how much how much is he
getting yeah um right around half a
million okay and how much is the house
price you're thinking about
buying um we were thinking like mid
threes okay right um is the settlement
taxed no it's not okay all right
um well let me uh send him a warning
through
you and you're not going to like this
okay okay there is no we you're not
married exactly there's a he coming I'm
coming into it yeah exactly there's a he
it's his money and so if he buys a house
it goes into his name not our name m
unless you're married are y'all getting
married um eventually we've been
together for six years so apparently
apparently not okay so um I mean six
years and you pain painter get off the
ladder I mean so you've already figured
out what you're doing but the um yeah I
if I'm him what's his what is his
income um right around uh 55 I think
okay so let's pretend for a second let's
just reverse engineer this so that
you'll it'll help you with your heart on
understanding where our voice advice is
coming from let's pretend that he made
$55,000 had $200,000 in the bank and a
paid for $300,000
house and you walked up to that guy and
you met that guy he had a paid for
$300,000 house $200,000 in the bank he
makes $55,000 a year would you then tell
him to go get a mortgage because that's
wise no same thing though isn't it mhm I
just did it
backward yeah it's the same exact thing
so the only thing that that could fall
under the heading of wisdom is if you if
it made sense and I don't think it does
and Georgia doesn't think it does to
borrow on your home to do
investing and effectively if you're
going to invest some let's say he put
100,000 down and instead of paying the
other 200 on the house put it in mutual
funds okay which is kind of what's
probably rattling around in the back of
your head somewhere
um I if if that makes sense then
borrowing on the paid for house to do
the same thing would also make
sense but by reverse engineering it it
makes you realize oh there's risk
involved here what was the can I know
you can't get into lawsuit details was
he injured for the settlement he was
yeah okay all right is he okay he's yeah
he's great now he can still work no
permanent damage to his income no
no it was it was a a miracle heill good
good I'm glad for him and you too yeah
so I would tell him to pay cash for his
house and and set aside an emergency
fund and invest the balance long term
and by the way if you don't have any
payments in the world and you make
$55,000 you could pay what's the
equivalent of a house payment into your
Investments every month and that alone
will make you a millionaire in just a
few
years okay does that make sense too it
does it does yeah yeah so that's what I
would do but
um uh
yeah those of you that are uh shacking
up and playing house or whatever you
want to call that stuff um be sure that
you keep your legal stuff completely
separate and you have to be careful even
with your pronouns in this case not like
woke pronouns but like pronouns like the
you have to get your we buying house
we're buying a house we aren't doing
anything he
is we're getting a settlement no he is
if you're married there's a we when
you're married you become French we we
right that's how that works but until
you're married there's not a Wei uh
legally I'm talking about um a
and honestly actually that also leaves
you in a
uh a predicament as well that I don't
want you in I would rather you have the
safe
in this relationship and the things that
you've been pouring into the the
economics you've been pouring into this
for six years I'd rather you have the
safety of marriage marriage represents
safety for you young lady so I I I would
just as a you know a guy who's seen all
the stuff go bad because that's all we
do we work with a lot of people who
where things went bad I I want I want
you to have a better life than than this
is setting up cuz you know one day he
just decided you're not there legally he
didn't have to do anything except tell
you to move he didn't even have to evict
you you don't even have tenants
rights you just move out you're a
squatter you know no equity nothing and
that's just um you know you don't want
to play that out for 90 years you don't
want to play that out I've been married
43 years you don't want to play that out
43 years and see how that looks it
doesn't this doesn't age well it's like
cheap wine it doesn't age well so you
know that that's just me loving you
right now telling you that for you
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life